what's going on there reject nation
we're gonna watch ourselves kingdom only
a few episodes left this is episode four
all right let's get to it if you guys
leave a like that'd be great and i want
to say thank you to the boys over at
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights check us on patreon if you
want to let's see what's going on
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's what they talked about in the
first episode
you're kind of chubby man
maybe you're eating a little too much
save some for her
oh
[Music]
i really like the way they choose to
reveal these moments
so do they need like perfect weather
can water cure them
bodies are comprised of water
largely maybe
wicked wow
[Music]
she literally
does everything
she is the absolute mvp everything falls
on her
[Music]
[Music]
full head of hair how
just love watching the slow spread of
information
and people grappling with the
information
so i don't think he can cure them but he
can prevent
maybe
[Music]
what happened to your face
were you [ __ ]
we all know how scary your uncle can see
no i shouldn't have saved him
lady if there's anyone who could cure
you with her yeah
could be better than before she's the
world's greatest leading scientist at
this point
she deserves some kind of national award
for
[Music]
tiny worm
jordan
[Laughter]
still just as blood hungry
i'm sure this actor is really nice in
real life
you have no idea lady
foreign
well you can feel the conflict in the
[ __ ]
faded blurred background yeah
it's the most intense staring contest
i've ever seen
wait what did she do wrong i i think
he's not in
in
the loop on the baby on the baby thing
yeah oh really looking after herself
with that i think
oh so he doesn't know about the baby
stuff
no
oh i thought he did
if i'm reading this right i think it's
that if she doesn't have a male prince
then it's up to him to to lead
whereas if she does then she can like
keep a hold on power while he grows up
[Music]
wow
i thought he knew it seems like the kind
of thing he would be okay
[Laughter]
pregnancies how many babies have you
gone through in this life
i was gonna say what's in that tea
oh what'd she do she straight up
poisoned him yeah i didn't think they
would do it
oh my god she is the real villain of
this show man that's crazy
that's [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
respect
my queen my queen i'm team queen now mvp
of the show
team queen
ruthless i looked down on you
i
thought you had no backbone
damn uh she's conniving team queen that
was great great twist yeah especially
for two people who didn't realize the
guy wasn't enough
he was totally i thought it was all his
idea
god now i'm thinking back like were
there were there ever seeds where she
was like we can't tell my dad
either way though jeez man
most likely that's a spirit and just get
some water and keep it close team queen
i hope she wins kill more women take
more babies
so many errors
you really are the crown princess
yo
how do they find this guy
i don't know in this day and age
a lot of letters a lot of like
second-hand accounts for people
best choice you've made all shows
losing respect
just to what he's told
so i had her beheaded
my keys are still here
oh jesus
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how is she supposed to study well when
you're deprived of one of your senses
all the others just pick right up
it's not bad
the most unfortunate scientist i've ever
seen
should have stayed out of trouble
it's not fair
it's not fair
queen
queen she's the bomb
i love her
love her
she's so cool
she's so cool man [ __ ]
dudes underestimated you i thought she
was nothing and boring i thought she was
boring as hell
not
one interesting thing about her i don't
think we've ever talked about her
not really
other than being a pawn in other
people's plans nah man that's what i
mean and then like the way this show
misleads you with having
uh
you know hot jew yeah him come back
having him come back yeah and you know
finding out something with the worms in
there and like a
link to the resurrection plant like
you're uncovering all this and he seems
like oh he's back and he's in charge and
he's gonna be ruthless and he's pissed
about some things
and then you actually just kill him off
in this episode yeah because she kills
him off and she was a little more clever
than him and had more foresight than he
did and i loved that yeah
badass truly his daughter going down
chang i've changed sides people of
shane's side
take over all of the kingdom take over
all the lands use the zombies enslave
our awesome scientist
sibo
so uh sophie sobi yeah goddamn it's hard
to remember
clearly for you it is
so be so big yeah
so be
yeah like so be just the most
unfortunate lady in the world constantly
being
imprisoned
cornered
and whisked also figuring out everything
for everyone well yeah people keep
dropping in on her and being like hey
come here really quick figure this out
all right we got to get you over here so
you can figure that out
and then someone's gonna take you away
from us to figure something out yeah
it's man it's messed up it's messed up
and
i just felt bad for her yeah felt bad
and very tense for her this episode but
the queen
oh so cool yeah yeah
and i mean just the whole it's funny
like i love the way they played that
whole showdown with them and the way
that they understated the thing with the
t because the thought crossed my mind
i'm like oh man she's probably poisoning
him or something and and yeah that that
way that he plays so much of that where
you know like yeah like we were kind of
fumbling over the episodes like i'm
thinking back of like did she establish
that she needed to keep this a secret
from him because the way he you know
goes in and talks to the whole council
as if you know he is very much trying to
cover this up like you see just how many
levels he has been working on and it
makes complete and total sense yeah that
the queen would then turn out to be so
much more conniving and it's fascinating
to watch sobe be
thrust in between the two of them and
like doing the things that you know are
just right because of what her vocation
is and the need to like i even even when
she reveals it to prince chang
i'm like okay the cost of keeping uh
hakju alive
is that we now know a little bit more
and we have a little bit more to go off
of but what is the you know immediate
cost of that and it's like it's it's
it's really intense and as much as you
can joke about like yeah man so be she
just like keeps peeing around and
figuring stuff out and this episode did
have a bit more of that like how much
time does it take to get from place to
place uh but uh yeah just like the way
that they have triangulated the sinister
true nature of this whole situation is
really stomach-dropping why did he
why did uh prince chang visit his uncle
i'm not sure yet i don't know if that's
got something to do with like he's
trying to figure out a new
i don't know alliance of some kind or or
what i i wasn't sure exactly where that
was headed just yet
i mean i like that scene between them
and i liked you know sort of the the
theme stated in that um but yeah i'm not
100 sure yet where that's going
or how they found him
but uh well this is the uh
we got two episodes left
yeah okay so you probably need some kind
of you know last piece of
information reassurance some kind of
familial i think we're in the middle of
a time jump about to happen
or something and i mean they they are
good at i think they're pretty good at
lacing those things in like i really
like the beginning of this episode after
we lose mu young in the last one
having that scene that that yeah you
called out as being brought up you know
as a as a memory they share in the first
episode
and then seeing it here realize was such
a nice kind of way to send him off in a
way that's also you know still quite
mournful and then to think that his baby
is the one who
you know is set to ascend the throne
although if i understand the queen's
plan he's even really a pawn at least as
of right now because the whole thing is
like you know there's a baby so she's
gonna be in charge de facto especially
with hawk jew out of the way
uh
i surprised he wasn't for the plan i
know i really thought it was his plan
the whole time
i'm really trying to think back because
i i can't yeah it's like i've i've
understood that there is that interplay
of yeah she's struggling to have a baby
and i feel like maybe now that i think
about it there is something of like i
can't let my dad know that i just
miscarried so maybe that maybe it was
there and i just forgot but um
but yeah it seems like the kind of thing
he would be
okay with because it's all about i feel
like if she doesn't
have the baby unless he just becomes the
de facto ruler then it's like they'd
lose their claim and it's you know
you've got prince chang who's like you
know his mother wasn't married to the
emperor when she had him so his claim is
like asterisked
and stuff so there's like a lot of
details that i feel like are easy to
kind of get jumbled in surrounding that
because they're they're both mothers in
a dubious position yeah well she's still
the ruler in the shadows yeah yeah
that's what i love about it
she's a badass yeah
she's as cold as ice man [ __ ] with her
man
yeah smoke a bolt or something
she's dope
yeah i would i want that to happen all
right that's great to see what that
would be like
i wonder how i feel about the whole uh
worm thingy
i'm
curious about
that oh please what about what were you
gonna say i was just chiming in on it i
didn't have a point sorry
no it's okay please i don't i don't have
anything i think you do yeah i'll go for
it it's okay i insist nah please be my
guest i'm okay i refuse
can i get that in writing
this is the worm thingy
they didn't establish okay so
is it like only if you're on the brink
of turning right you can't like turn
someone back
that's right right that's kind of like
the impression i got that's the
impression i got is if you're yeah if
you're on the brink it can probably
it's like cutting somebody's arm off in
a normal zombie movie
you know if they got bit on the hand if
you just sever the hand they're like
maybe you could stop it it feels like
that kind of a turn
yeah or that kind of a rule it's like we
can submerge you before you start
bleeding from the mouth
you know
there's this uh
um old-time radio story
called revolt of the worms
you know like uh earthworms a real
natural part
of our world
and how this world in some ways can
belong to them oh yeah and uh so i think
on some type of very metaphorical level
it because of what i liked about the
zombie play in this it's not some
scientist has created something with
monkeys or
her meteor has crashed or yeah you know
it's radiation from altitude
yeah it's not any of that
it's something from the earth that can
do it and this is like uh earth taking
over like there's a conversation to be
had about
maybe this is a natural order of the way
things should go
or maybe we're supposed to be eating
plants
just not this plant
because then we'll be eating each other
well it's it's neat but when you die
you know like you think about every
horror movie you've ever seen of when
like bodies are popping up from like
coffins or something there's usually
maggots and worms
you know that are like feasting on your
body in the dirt
and so i think there is something kind
of cool about like making it just that
enhances that quality a little bit more
of
the living dead
and so the worms eating the host they're
driving the host to eat more yeah no i
mean uh that's cool i wrote a story that
actually dealt exactly with with that
that was about worms controlling yeah
and uh so it's kind of weird to see hey
this guy right here
but not in like that's
not that same no no no it's definitely
not the same but
like oh it's a zombie i wrote a story
about a queen was getting a bunch of
babies together
i didn't even know there were worms in
there yeah it surprised me like cut them
open there's not like worms popping out
or something just like a couple of worms
i guess they like must nest deep and
then sense the water and they're like we
got to get out of here or or something i
don't know
like but
if you hold a torch right next to the
place where they're coming out as
they're submerged in the water you'll
just watch them go through this crisis
of which one's worse
but uh it didn't make me question
i was like okay oh so wait
the zombie phenomenon then is due to
these worms
because they lay the eggs on this plant
do they only lay eggs on the plant does
the plant play a role or does it just
happen to be that these eggs were on
that plant and thus the plant got called
the resurrection plant when really it's
these resurrection worms that are doing
the the because it's
was maybe a little thrown off
yeah can the worms only hatch
if their body if they're attached to a
human host yeah and what happens if you
like happen to only get some plant juice
into somebody and not worm juice into
somebody worm eggs
i don't know
i hope the next episode spends the whole
hour
just explaining the rules it's a
real-time research session with sophie
just being like oh goodness though
one take one shot and start talking to
the camper uncut yeah this is a
monologue it's a soliloquy it's a ted
talk this is the most boring episode of
television i've ever seen that was an
expo dump jesus
don't write a script for this episode
just just feed the audience what they
need to know so that we can get this
finale on the road
yeah
all right well we got two more to go
and how's mu young gonna get out of this
or prince chang has prince chang new
young
he's out of this avoiding every and all
conflict at this point
young's is in the safest position
possible
um yeah is wife dead
is that it
i mean it's his baby so i think she is
like hanging on for dear life right now
she's like in shock if i if that was who
they who they have uh
so be talked to it must be her god i'm
hating that guy yeah
i'm hating him yeah
he used to be like an affable goofy
like he's gonna be the amusing and i
thought like oh he might be the gay you
know like oh he's not like his family
but i'm like you just you make things
worse but every turn
that's how he stays alive
she's an [ __ ] by being the worst
oh god
it's so annoying
because if he'd spoke up about anything
he'd probably be dead by now
he's the worst yeah
and what's he going to do grass is our
physician yeah
what's what's uh what's he gonna do as
the queen's guard
i mean she's just gonna she's he's not
gonna make any decisions
i guess not i guess that's just a hey
stay out of the way
who's the one who would not oppose my
authority at all who's the one that
would not question my authority
whatsoever
and who could just command the troops
places yeah
sorry guys i don't know if something
massaging my half my body really hurts
it's okay next episode we'll just do we
want a table reacting well that'd be the
best reaction so to shoot some of your
reactions i will massage you oh i was
getting massaged for a reaction
a table with a hole in it and put it in
an angle so that you can watch them like
just kind of taste on 12 hours straight
filming yes
like put your head through the hole and
go
so my body hurts my whole my affects
everything my facial expressions my my
whole my all everything about me just
i'm just not not as emotive
oh and think of all the the extra
emotions you would get during a massage
releasing the repressed emotions that
are stored in the body yeah so it'll be
a human experience and a tv experience
and which reaction goes to which part
you know portion
who knows
engaging
content how about you when i get
massages i go
just go hard yeah just get it out go
hard i'm going to be making a lot of
faces but it's fine you're going to be
in a lot of pain part of this massage as
much as i come as much as i came in here
for the relief and the release i also
came in here to be like physically
challenged yeah to not say
stop to get it out just get it out yeah
i don't care how much it hurts oh my god
so much pain work that knot
ah
crack
all right guys we're done
[Music]